you see the the numbers and see you so
28th in the nba you see the 30
30th in the end being a three-point
percentage and 29th in the nba
in field percentages towns knocks down
that three
just under six minutes to go in the game
plenty of time timberwolves come up with
it aaron gomez
and wacho c senor with the dunk
[Music]
you know guys are cutting into the paint
taking oh what a nice dish
over the shoulder to a cutting mcdaniels
unbelievable that was
arvida sabonis like right there bill
walton like
cut initially and then came back from
the dunker area to get that
pass from towns kale and parish getting
to the free throw line
because it gave him a chance to kind of
collect his thoughts and figure out what
he wanted to do
cat connects on a triple i love it his
fourth of the game
and suddenly it's a two-point contest
he's six of 23 in the game
i mean that's ridiculous and other other
guys were getting getting it done in
towns
has been the mvp here baby houston's
last 12 possessions
three turnovers of 10 from the field
and towns able to get it to a
three-point game
he's six of 25 now
the rockets have turned it over 21 times
karl-anthony towns has been
clutch daniels now
and he's played well tonight mcdaniels
with 13 points in the game four rebounds
and he's also perfect at the line two
for two so a perfect night for him
shooting the wall keeping minnesota in
this game when things
did not look like he was going to go
their way macklemore no
the tim wolves closed the game on a 20
to nothing run houston missed its final
13
shots did not score